Disney have given their animated Aladdin
a live-action makeover but is this as
shining shimmering and splendid as the
original yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm
John and today I'm explaining the top
ten differences between the new Aladdin
movie and the classic film from 1992 I'm
also kicking off a new giveaway so
subscribe hit the bell and leave a
comment about the movie for a chance to
win Robin Williams iconic performance as
a genie in Disney's animated Aladdin is
totally unforgettable and beloved by
generations of children and adults alike
what better way to make your grand
entrance on the streets of Agrabah than
riding your very own job they spit
obviously no one could ever hope to
recreate the very specific genius of
Williams madcap impersonation filled
turn so when it came to retelling that
story a different approach was needed
and that's what Will Smith gives us with
his particular interpretation of the
shape-shifting grantor of wishes why
aren't you playing hard to win like
Williams did so successfully in the
animated movie Smith brings his own
special energy to the role of the
live-action genie injecting some of his
larger-than-life personality into the
part one summons me I stand by my oath
loyalty two wishes three I'm kidding
Russell so expect a genie with some
swagger and also a light Fresh Prince of
bel-air flavor to his songs Smith's
charismatic take on the character soon
makes his own impression and now for
your card to Raj
too small too obvious
he really is a lot of burning gets
plenty of laughs including some great
back-and-forth with Aladdin and some of
the other palace residents Lena Massoud
gets a lot in this cheeky charm just
right and has a cool comic rapport with
the genie Wow
do we need the top nine that's my little
cherry on top and a lovely on-screen
chemistry with Naomi Scots jasmine sure
tea how did you get past the guards that
was challenging
you cannot just break into a palace like
you own the place if you don't have
anything you have to act like you own
everything
overall Masood shines best in the movies
comedic moments so he really makes the
most of some of the additional scenes
that Aladdin gets in this version
including a big dance number while he's
basically orchestrated by the genie and
a hilarious scene where he meets his
future father-in-law and clumsily tries
to charm his way into the Sultan and
Jasmine's good books as for Aladdin's
costume well that's undergone some
changes too with his birch ested
waistcoat look in the animation getting
an extra shirt in the new film Jasmine's
outfit also gets an update to cover up
more in the live-action version of
course both characters clothes still
heavily echoed their animated attire and
Jasmine in particular gets some stunning
new looks
Zoe Scott gives a fantastic performance
as Jasmine who gets a much more active
role in the new film compared to the
animated movie in the live-action
version Jasmine's desire to make her own
decisions and choices in life goes
beyond simply wanting to experience a
bit of life outside the palace and marry
a man she actually loves how do you wall
of you standing around deciding my
future I am NOT a prize to be won now
Jasmine questions why woman shouldn't
have political as well as personal power
you want to be Sultan but why I have
been preparing for this my whole life
for example she asks how a foreign
prince would look after the people of
Agrabah better than she would you have
no idea what is happening out there I
can tell him as she knows and cares for
them and wants to improve their lives
this Jasmine know she has something to
offer as a leader not just as a romantic
partner and we also get some back story
about Jasmine's family and why the
Sultan is so overprotective of his
daughter Alan Menken Howard
Sherman Tim Rice's classic songs from
Arabian Nights to Prince Ali and a whole
new world which you know and love from
the original movie are all there in the
new film with a few updated lyrics and a
touch of hip hop on some of Will Smith's
joonie tracks there's also a brand new
song for Princess Jasmine called
speechless which Naomi Scott totally
knocks out of the park
[Music]
think frozen's let it go meets this is
me from the greatest showman in fact it
was written by Disney legend Alan Menken
with Benj PASOK and Justin Paul the
award-winning Joe behind la-la land and
the greatest showman oh and there's a
cool curtain call with the cast busting
some moves to friend like me and we get
a more full on hip-hop version of that
song sung by Will Smith during the end
credits before the film came out
reactions to the new Jafar were mixed
with some saying he didn't seem as
intimidating as his animated counterpart
bring me the lab I knew the lamp
the rest was yours but the lamp is mine
in fact the movies production designer
revealed they wanted to make Jafar more
evil so during reshoots they built him a
dungeon to do more nefarious things in
the new film certainly reveals an even
darker past which afar filling in his
backstory before he became the Sultan's
trusted adviser and providing an
interesting comparison between him and
Aladdin however this true father still
seemed to lack some of the animated
villains menace
also while live-action Jafar uses a
snake headed staff to mesmerize people
like in the animation don't worry he
doesn't need disguises to trick Aladdin
into doing what he wants you stumbled
upon an opportunity there's a cave
nearby and in it a simple oil lab
Jafar's parrot sidekick Iago doesn't get
as much screen time in the live-action
movie as he did in the original
animation he does still go out spying on
the other characters for his master in
the new film and even gets a big action
scene but don't expect to see him in the
sort of crazy slapstick moments that
were a big part of his character in the
1992 movie
[Music]
Ian hey another difference between
live-action and animated Yago is how
they sound as voiced my Gilbert
Gottfried in the original animation he
spoke with a regular parrot voice when
people like the Sultan were around I was
by which Aden weren't saving his true
wisecracking cantankerous personality
for scenes with Jafar I can't take it
anymore if I got a joke down like one
more knows moldy disgusting crackers
however in the live-action version where
he's voiced by Disney regular Alan Tudyk
Jafar's feathered friends sticks to
typical parrot talk whenever he speaks
that's what I said that's what I said
director Guy Ritchie told aw he wanted
to ground the film's peripheral
characters in some degree of reality so
I think the movies squawky parrot voice
is part of adding a bit more of a sense
of realism to the animal characters in a
similar way to how the mice didn't speak
in the live-action Cinderella like
Jafar's parrot Aladdin's pet monkey is a
completely computer-generated creation
in the new film
unlike Iago though a boo gets lots more
time on screen interacting with his
owner Aladdin retains a lot of the fun
personality of the original which is
great because he has some really nice
moments however like with the Argo the
semi intelligible monkey talk from the
animation doesn't make it into the
live-action version in the same way the
live-action movie introduces several new
characters and my favorite of these is
Dalia Jasmine's handmaiden and friend
who get some delightfully funny scenes
with not just the princess but also
Aladdin and Genie she's played by
actress Nasim pedrad who's best known
for Saturday Night Live and the side by
comedy people of Earth which was sadly
cancelled way too soon for drag turns in
a scene stealing performances Dalia
really wringing the best out of every
moment she's on screen Jasmine's father
the Sultan gets a personality makeover
in the live-action movie instead of the
bumbling and pompous but generally
good-natured ruler we saw in the
original film have a play pretty party
your Majesties
[Music]
nice Olson is wiser and more dignified
it's a pleasure to welcome you to
October France earlier and we also get
some new backstory about the Sultan's
wife Jasmine's mother instead of the
animations cruel and arrogant Prince
Achmed who almost whipped two young
children in the street before he was
stopped by a lad in the live-action
movie gives us a different potential
suit of a Princess Jasmine this new
Prince Anders is from a fictional place
called Scotland a rather than being
constantly annoyed like Achmed he's more
bumbling and idiotic however when Prince
Anders meets jasmine and Rajah fans of
the original may notice a little Easter
egg to have Jasmine's Tiger reacts to
the prince and I'll be delving deeper
into those Easter eggs from the original
movie in my next Aladdin video I'll add
a link to that on the screen here and in
the video description as soon as it's
ready now it's time for you to decide
which Aladdin is better I've added a
poll where you can vote just tap in the
top of this video and after you've cast
your vote you'll be able to see the
results let me know what you think in
the comments below and subscribe to
enter my alighting giveaway tapleft for
my next Aladdin video or tap write for
another video you're sure to like thanks
for watching and see you next time you
pick a movie lovers